okay
thanks all right so welcome back to the
second part of my talk
we'll what I'll talk about next is um
new error models so insertion dels and
erasers um and in particular locally
decodable codes for insertion and
addition and locally recoverable or
local reconstruction codes for um eraser
coding so I'll just kind of start a
little bit uh slowly with insertion and
dels because we haven't had any kind of
intro um onto um this model uh Le this
week um
and uh let me quickly Define the edit
distance between two strings X and Y
it's the minimum number of insertions
and deletions to transform x uh into y
okay so for instance in in this example
here um the eded distance between X and
Y is four because um I have to uh uh um
delete to zero and insert one uh in the
first position and delete zero and
insert one in the third
position okay
um one can if you think a little bit
about um one can show that the edit edit
distance between uh two strings uh is
lower bounded by twice the hemming
distance so if the Heming if the edit
distance is large then the hemming
distance uh is large but the edit
distance could be much much smaller um
than the heav distance um so one can
Define
um um codes for um for insertion and
deletions um and um
decoders uh that um are able to recover
messages this is in the standard
classical decoding setting where uh
we're given
um received Vector of size n and we we
want to uh decode to the message X when
we have a let's say constant fraction of
in insertions of or dels um and uh just
as before uh the relative one can Define
the relative Min minimum distance of a
code um
to to be so here the normalization
factor is 2 m because we want it to be
in 01 um we also have the same notion of
rate the same goals as before we want
um good codes so codes with constant
rate constant distance this would be in
the classical setting um and algorithms
that are uh efficient for both encoding
and
decoding okay so um insertion delion
codes were introduced in the 60s by
Levenstein uh but only um in 99 Schulman
and zuk zukerman came up with a first
construction of uh good codes that also
have efficient in coding and decoding
algorithm so about 30 years later um
however recently people have really
picked up um on uh on insertion delici
codes and there is quite a lot of work
in the recent years um that kind of try
to get the best parameters and efficient
decoding and um list decoding variants
um and if you want to read more about it
there are some excellent surveys um uh
that I'm listing here okay so what about
local insertion Del codes um I I found
this quote um in a paper in nature
materials um where um um where
essentially uh so people uh who work in
um DNA storage and DNA storage
Technologies they care about uh Random
Access into their data so that they can
quickly retrieve um files from a
database and this is exactly right so um
ability to efficiently retrieve specific
files or arbitrary subset of files this
is exactly the motivation uh that we
have for constructions of locally
decodable code uh so in particular in
DNA storage the type of Errors we see
are insertions and deletions so that's
why um um DNA storage is kind of an
application domain for such code um okay
so how do we start even think thinking
about what kind of um how can we come up
with a locally decodable insertion
deletion codes and maybe the first thing
to think about is well we have all these
constructions all all this literature on
um hemming locally decodable codes um
can we somehow leverage it to get uh
insertion divis codes and it turns out
that that's indeed the case so the first
paper that considered local decodable
caes by OSI parin and uh
Chavi um and I can prove the following
statement that if you take a hemming
locally decodable codes with Q queries
um correcting a Delta fraction of
hemming errors you can somehow massage
it into an Insel insertion deletion
locally decodable codes um where the
query just blows up by poly log uh M so
I'm kind of switching from K to and in
the first part of the talk to end to M
here but hopefully it will be clear um
from the context um so poly log length
of uh the code word um blow up in the
query complexity um and uh with a
constant blow up in the rate and
constant blow up in the distance yes um
sorry is is there a Sigma different from
bits or um yeah this is a binary code so
they build a binary code uh requirement
on is can Sigma any alphabet start code
or there there is a sigma somewhere in
here um somewhere in the thetas but yeah
I don't remember exactly so instead of
instill uh can you just consider a
deletion uh only model just a deletion
yes that that would surprise normal uh
result like instead of insertion oh wait
um no no I think you actually you need
insertion and deletion I see yeah that's
a good
question that's a good question
yeah
um
although let me let me think about it it
might not be I'm kind of blanking now on
that but um dels might be just
enough let let me think about it
um so anyways we can take hemming ldcs
and pack them up into insertion delion
hem um ldcs with not too bed of a loss
in um in the parameters um and uh the
only bad thing that happens is that the
query complexity blows up a little bit
um so this is something that we also
reproved uh bunch of years after this
result we kind of rediscovered and
reproved it and kind of that's what got
us interested in uh this area and by now
there are many other uh works on locally
decodable codes um so let's quickly just
kind of uh see what uh this reduction
gives us in terms of um inel LDC uh
tradeoffs um so if we take uh the the
had aart code the have uh Heming um LDC
with query 2 and exponential length um
we is essentially get nothing
interesting uh so that's uh we can skip
it uh for constant query complexity um
the the upper bound is sub exponential
here but because of the blow up we get
um we we get
um pretty bad uh rate uh in the
transformation as well and um the only
regime where things start to be
interesting is this poly logam regime uh
where you get um polog and query uh
instel ldcs with um message length that
is sub
quadratic okay um okay so and and and
the next uh interesting regime is uh the
um um kind of and to the little of one
query complexity uh where you get uh uh
con constant rate so uh with log n to
the log log n queries you can get a
constant rate locally decodable
insertion
Del okay
so I'm just going to next give you a
little bit more intuition about this
reduction just to see how we work with
insertion deletion codes um and
um um this is going to be a very high
level
overview the reduction is perhaps
something you would expect it's a a
concatenation uh so we have a uh an
outer code which is a Hamming LDC so
this um code is going to be able to uh
decode each bit um I if uh hemming
errors um occur um and then we're going
to compose it with an inner code uh
which is uh the the shman zman code that
I just mentioned before um which
essentially has uh constant rate
constant distance linear time
decoding so we're going to obtain a
binary uh uh code that looks like this
um so we take the um the the LDC code
word and we're going to break it into
chunks um and then we're going to um
kind of label each chunk by its uh
position in the um code um and uh we're
going to encode with the shman zman code
both the information in in the trun
itself um as well as the position um of
the Chun and that's that's kind of like
the hard thing in insertion Del is to
figure out where um where uh each bit um
ended up right because with
um erasur we know exactly where the data
is
with and so so is the case with bit
flips but um I mean location stay the
same that's what I'm trying to say but
here with insertions and deletions uh
locations might change and a lot of work
might be needed to figure out where um
each location ended up okay
um after after this step we we add some
extra buffers to kind of make sure that
we can separate the
information uh bits from from kind of
each other we separate information bits
um and each of these buffers as well as
um the code um is going to have size
about log M
bits okay and and um just to to remind
you you this is essentially where the
blow up occurs the log M um um blow
up um okay
so if there are no errors how do you
figure out um the value of a message at
position I um we simply simulate the
local decoder the outer decoder right
it's going to tell us where the queries
what queries to make
then I go to the position of the queries
I decode figure out what the value was
at that query use the outer decoder um
and output the bit that I care about
okay
so um things are great if there are no
errors um we just need to decode the
this information chunks and we have good
decoders algorithm for that algorithms
for that and uh as I mentioned um the
challenges here are are searching for an
index in a corrupted code word and and
also finding the buffers turns out to be
a
challenge so the properties uh that uh
that are helpful of
the the shman zukerman code um are um
essentially rate distance and and
decoding time but also there is this
third fourth property which um
essentially says that for every interval
of length k um there are many ones in
the uh in coding so that there the
weight is large so we have fractional
hemming weight at least 2
f um and um the implications of uh kind
of like where does this help us um so
one two and three implies polylog M
query time right so we need to decode uh
each information information that
long
time um and the property for it it helps
us figure out where the buffers are
because we can simply kind of test the
density of ones uh in these blocks and
figure out where we have uh information
blocks and where we have um
um buffers with just a few queries okay
so how do we find block J in the
corrupted code word with insertion
delici um errors um the idea here is
essentially a binary search but it's in
a it's in a a noisy uh setup um
so the reason it works is because most
of the blocks appear in the correct
order um and um and so um and
also
um there are some nice combinatorial
property um of of the bits that we can
actually
um recover the positions that we can
recover so I don't want to say too much
about but um this is a kind of like a
cute uh Toy problem to figure out how do
you perform noisy uh binary search um on
an array that is kind of Delta far from
s okay so this leads us to a question um
of the form is binary search inherent to
locally decodable yes right now we're
assuming an alphabet of right but in DNA
the example right it wasum it's Base
Four you think that would also
substantively change that shouldn't
change anything that shouldn't even
though each character would have
more there are ways to I mean it's it's
constantly many bit ASM totically should
be exactly the same okay
yeah um okay
so so so is binary search in inherent to
locally decodable codes and if you see
what I'm driving at is
um can we get a locally decodable codes
with fewer queries do I have to perform
login queries or maybe I can do
something smarter and get constant
constantly many uh queries uh insertion
delis um so this is some it's in some
sense an open problem I'm I'll tell you
more about it um soon um
but um in in kind of recentish results
um where we're interested in precisely
this question what happens in the
constant query regime right we have uh
very an immediate two query um hemming
LDC right the the hadamard uh code can
we come up with constantly many queries
um insertion deletion code so we tried
very hard and we couldn't come up with
anything and it turns out that
um such things don't exist if if we're
looking for linear insertion delici
codes they don't exist with two queries
that's one of um our results um and in
general we kind of reproved the the
inherited lower bound from the hemming
case uh of exponential exponential and
um uh code word length um and uh so
these extend uh to exponential lower
bounds for U constantly many queries and
even to uh the regime of about Logan
over log
login so anyways these are um kind of
like the first results uh about uh
locally decod insertion deltion locally
decodable codes uh with constantly many
queries
um some of these results um can be
extended in the case of relaxed locally
decodable codes right I I just mentioned
that for relaxed locally decodable codes
you actually can get a dramatic uh drop
in the code or length um for constant
query because you're allowed to answer
bot sometimes um it turns out that that
notion of weak versus strong um uh rld
see uh uh those two Notions are not
actually equivalent for insertion and
deletion code so we prove a separation
here
um and in particular the strong lower
bonds do have the strong insertion dele
codes so those that satisfy all three
properties must have exponential length
even though we're talking about relaxed
uh versions um and uh constantly many
queries um but the weak variants um
actually behave like the Hemming
varant um okay so next I want to say I
kind of uh I want to there was a
question um so I want to give you a
little bit of intuition about um how uh
what we can say about queries uh in this
case so when we looked at uh all these
algebraic families um the queries looked
very nice we restricting to subspaces to
lines um that there was a lot of
structure on the queries and there was a
lot of algebraic structure what happens
U um in the case of insertion deletions
um it turns out that that all of that is
kind of lost we have no algebraic
structure to to work with but there are
other interesting things happening here
so let me
um um start by saying that um
okay
so um we're going to be looking at error
patterns dele patterns that are going to
make uh the decoder work hard okay so
that's how we're going to think about
lower bonds are going to come up with
families with with distributions over uh
the error patterns that uh will make the
decoder uh perform any queries and uh
I'm only going to talk about this error
pattern which is a very basic pattern
you uh pick a random number e and chop
off that many um uh positions from the
received word at the beginning so you
receive this and then you just delete um
e many um entries from the beginning and
this is what you
receive okay so what can we say about
this um error pattern um if we look at
the
queried
um indices I'm denoting them here as K
and K plus D um K plus d means really
distance D from K so the first query is
at position K and then um I'm counting
the many positions from k um and that's
where the second query is um and for
this particular error pattern if I query
the the tople K and K plus D um it it it
should have come
from a topple upstairs right so in the
uncorrupted code word that uh is of the
form K plus e and K plus C plus d so the
observation here is that the distance
between queries stays the same right so
we have a distribution of queries here
that induces another distribution um
upstairs
um and um essentially we we need to
understand such uh distribution um
such um yeah distributions so one may
ask can we come up with a insert inel
ldcs for this particular error pattern
so it's it's just a simple type of
errors that you are allowed to make um
it turns out that some massaging of the
hadamar code that we've seen before
actually does work so if you recall the
uh to the code at position I you pick a
and a plus e plus here means uh sorry A
Plus EI I so plus means binary um
addition here
um here is kind of the analog of uh what
you need to do to decode um from inel
errors you pick a random pair a distance
2 to the I minus one so we we assume
lexical graphic ordering um it turns out
that
um that with some
massaging um the hadamar code um is um
is a local uh decodable codes when um um
for this particular error
pattern so what I'm trying to get at
here is that um algebraic structure kind
of gets thrown out of the window but
there is more of some sort of a
geometric structure here so the queries
have distance
um like um other Notions of distance
between um okay
so
that's and and the final proof that you
need to work uh harder to come up with
with u distributions of errors that um
provably will require you to make
exponentially many
queries that's the strategy of the
proof um so quickly summarizing what
we've seen so far you can transform a
Heming LDC into an inel LDC with a pol
logam a blow up but constant loss in a
rate and distance this has no
implication in the constant query regime
but um we have now results that are
exponential lower Bound for constant
query in the ldcs and in that paper we
actually uh conjectured that there do
not exist
um constant query LS and this was
recently proved in a breakthrough result
of U migal Gupta who's a student here at
uh Berkeley um she shows single-handedly
that constant query in ldcs do not exist
by kind of taking our techniques to to
the next level this is a very impressive
work and it's also just a very recent uh
paper um so uh there are still questions
like
what exactly you can still get uh
between constant and polog what
um what can you construct what uh other
lower bounds one can prove um another
thing that we've been interested and and
didn't get far is applications so um
Hamming ldcs have lots of applications
throughout um
umcs can we come up with any analogies
um that that are meaningful in the
instel version probably in the data
structure world one can but
um it would be interesting to see uh
what else uh can be done with
in a quick question I probably missed
that what is Theta of one loss in
decoding radius oh I me just constant
blow up in the uh rate and distance in
the distance it will go down yeah
distance will go down what what was the
it actually like what was the original
the
constant I mean it's it's constant goes
down from a constant
to another constant
um so it's just a transformation you
take your Hamming
LDC um and just think like having L is
what is the decoding radius is it that's
just one no the distance not not the
decoding oh I said decoding radius sorry
I me distance sorry yeah this should be
distance um I see um so the distance
would become sorry what to
what um so sorry it's the amount of
error right so loss in the rate and the
amount of error that you can
withand and so if you withstand
uh with the previous LDC I yeah it's
just
yeah that's okay yeah um more
questions okay
so okay I think this time I went really
fast I'm um I'm here
um talking
about um codes for distributed storage
and eraser uh coding um and uh this
dramatic picture uh was uh is courtesy
of Mii uh who uh it's apparently CH GPT
generated uh when you ask it for uh
distributed storage is supposed to show
bettered for uh distributed storage uh
so
anyways what are those things I don't
know
no no these are drones
right
yeah yeah they're erasing some
data very yeah exactly yeah it's the
worst case but let me tell you about the
worst
case yeah it makes sense so um okay so
codes for distributed storage um so
there are a couple of um the itas that
we' like to have when we talk about
distributed storage um and in
particular data centers are hierarchical
we want to kind of model that um um
failers are viewed as eraser we know
whether or node failed or not so it's an
eraser um and here unlike the locally
decodable setting we don't care about um
asymptotically many errors or here
erasur but but we typically care about
constantly many so like one two three um
small number of erasers that we want to
uh kind of very quickly uh fix um and we
kind of also need to capture um recovery
from nearby chunks of data and uh and we
also need to be resilient to many
erasures globally so if something bad
happens like in that picture globally we
still want to be able to um
um
recover so pictorially um we
can think of eraser codes um in in this
manner we have data broken into uh
chunks um chunks of kind of small size
um and we um uh we add some parities
that are parities only on on the bits of
the chunks um and then we also need to
to add some global parities so these are
parities over um um bits that could
belong to multiple chunks so chunks at
uh at larger
distance okay um so an uh LH locally
local reconstruction code that encodes K
symbols into n symbols uh has to correct
H+ one simultaneous errors and it needs
to recover any single uh erased symbol
by accessing that most most L other
symbols so kind of this uh smaller
chunks are supposed to be of size um L
and the the bigger the the global
parities are supposed to correct these
um additional um eraser patterns that
might not be uh not necessarily
locally okay
so as an example uh starting from r own
code we can get um
somewhere um close to this goal but um
um so these are called pyramid codes
what we can do is recover uh message
bits um and the idea is um as
follows um so we start with the r solmon
code okay so an nkd code um it has um um
um k um oh sorry I I mean to say uh D
minus one parity checks so n is um n
minus d+1 it's an MDS code it has D
minus one parity checks um now assume
that one of these parity is a global
parity in the sense of in the sense that
it it's like the XR of every single bit
um
and we're going to replace This Global
parity by uh more local local parities
uh so um replace it by let's say k over
L many local parities one per
chunk let's assume that K is divisible
by um L um and uh therefore we we get um
a code of length um just what we had
before K plus D minus 2 these Global
parities plus K Over L is local parities
um and um it turns out that such a code
does match the singl turn Bound for
lrc's which I'm actually going to talk
about next uh and it has the property
that each um message bit can actually be
recovered from from L other
bits um and um but but you you cannot
recover locally the
global okay so read Solon codes get get
us some leverage but um more work needs
to be done
um so the Singleton bound uh for uh
lrc's um uh looks as follows so as
before in the classical setting the
amount of redundancy is at least D minus
one here the amount of redundancy is um
at least K Over L plus um D plus2 so if
you replace L by uh K if you actually
don't have any locality you uh you
recover the sing b um and uh in a
beautiful work of T and Bar in 14
um um they came up with an explicit
construction of Co that achieve this
bound uh using a subcode of red solmon
code um and what's interesting here or
what people care about here is also the
the size of the field so we want fields
that are of small size and and they
achieve this with linear size
Fields
okay
um now another uh question that people
ask when they uh think about lrc codes
is um what among all lrc codes that have
the same parameters which ones are
better so there are some that correct
some eraser pattern some that some that
correct other Erasure p patterns um is
there a codee that corrects all possible
correctable eraser
patterns um and such a code is called
the maximally recoverable codes and it
turns out that such things do exist so
um Maxim recoverable codes U exist um
but the caveat is that they exist um
uman the this the um um basic proof um
um only shows uh the existence of such
things over large Fields
exponentially uh large uh
Fields okay so one of the big questions
in this area is what is the smallest
field size for maximum recoverable uh
locally locally
uh uh maximum recoverable lrc's um and
can we come up with explicit
construction so this is actually
not an explicit construction
um
okay so there is a lot of work in this
area and uh and I should just point you
to experts in the audience like um like
ARA and Mary has worked in this area and
of course um van cut who has worked on
everything um and so there are many
works that are
incomparable um but but uh some kind of
more um um uniform constructions so
constructions that work over all ranges
of parameters uh come from these two
papers um and uh the the bond that they
get looks like this I mean it looks a
bit weird but think of L as being a
constant for instance locality we care
about small locality um this would give
us end to uh a minimum number of um
Global um um
parities uh um L is the uh the length of
the local group and a is the number of
parities so a is always smaller uh a is
the number of parities in inside each
local group so I showed you for it
almost just one parity but you could
have a um more um more par inside each
um group so this um these are R CS work
for correcting up to Alpha erasers in
each local group um and AG additional
Global
per okay
so of practical interests again um a
being one to three and H being small um
um these are very common settings um so
for such bonds we get kind of Po nomial
size field so that's not too bad um
there is also work on Lower bounds um
and
uh the there are some lower bounds that
um are super super linear um for some
ranges of parameters that I I am not
going to um get into
um so in terms
of
strategies of um proving upper and lower
bounds um this is uh something I I just
pretty much every paper
um looks at um this Matrix the if you
think a little bit about it the parity
check Matrix of such codes um has this
nice form um so basically it's it's very
sparse and uh the local groups the
parity on local groups um
um uh is um
um um associated with these small
matrices AI that kind of come um come
off diagonal um and and then the global
parities um are captures by kind of the
last uh matrices uh B1 B2 um u b g here
um and uh so bis and AIS have
appropriate Dimensions um and
um the strategy from here
on um is to analyze the terminant of
these matrices or rank of these matrices
um when the AIS and bis have kind of
special forms nice forms um um and in
particular um some of the matrices that
appear again and again um in these
papers um are matrices that look like
vender mon um which are nice because um
they're determinant is non zero if the
alpha eyes are are
not if the alpha eyes are distinct
um and uh there generalizations over um
uh
finite Fields let's say if Q to the N
here um so these are matrices whose
determinant is not non zero when the
alpha eyes are linearly independent over
fq um and um there are the recent paper
that I just mentioned
um uh here the kind of recent
breakthrough in this area um uses
something called skew polinomial um
these are uh
pols that have uh roots of very special
uh structure they form uh
subspaces um and um they
um it it's
um they're kind of really hard to to
understand I can't I wanted to put
something for you to see but um it's uh
they're not that easy to to describe so
there is a whole theory developed in
this paper um or or it's been developed
before but they kind of
um um rewrite it in a way that uh is
attracted TOS um and it's probably it's
probably the case that such polinomial
will have further
applications uh so
um this is actually my last slide I
think this time I went too too fast
while last time I went too slowly uh but
anyways
um uh we we haven't talked about many
many other local codes that people have
considered um so local regeneration
codes these are um also codes for uh
Erasure uh uh
um uh for for um distributed uh uh data
um but where uh instead of the number of
servers access we care about the
communication um performed between um
the server so we want to minimize the
communication um locally updatable codes
so these are codes that are more um
relevant to
cryptography um it's about kind locally
changing um a code in order to get to
another code um approximate local
decoding local list decoding that's
again something that I I um haven't
covered at all so this is in the setting
when uh we go beyond unique decoding the
amount of error is larger than half the
minimum
distance um local codes in
computationally bounded channels um
these are codes also kind of more
relevant to to
cryptography um um in the setting where
the adversary doesn't have all the time
in the world to come up with the worst
case erasion eraser pattern but it's um
It's Time
bounded it has to come up with a an
Erasure or the worst erasion eras or
like um um error pattern within a Time
bound or within a Space Bound um and so
what what can we do in that
setting um find finally there is work on
Quantum locally decodable codes and very
recently I saw paper Again by vut on
Quantum locally recoverable uh codes um
and yes so there is a ton of work out
there uh the conclusion of the talk that
is that we we've just um scratched the
surface um so anyways that's uh that's
it from me uh thank you for your
attention
again we have time for
questions uh I have a question actually
going back quite a bit you had this
thing about the insertion deletions you
asked can you beat the noisy binary
search and you didn't say much about it
but I think on your slide it said you
can if I saw that right I was wonder if
you can say a bit about said where did
they say
that
maybe read it's said
before was in some primet range right it
was possible to beat um
the I just want the question was uh
what's the trick what's the trick we
don't we don't know I I definitely
shouldn't have said that you can it's an
open
question yeah
somewhere here should
be
there
okay yeah is binary search in inherent
to
was after
this ah oh I think I talked about
relaxed locally locally decodable
codes a relaxed locally decodable codes
okay I assum it's relaxed okay yeah for
the relaxed version you can I mean you
can get constant queries so if you just
need to satisfy the two the first two
property of um relax decoding um which
is completeness and um the fact that uh
for each message bit you should output
either the correct bit or bot with
probability to thirds so that's the weak
version um you can actually um you can
you can read it in the sense of there
are constant query and then what's
what's the trick there I
mean so the trick there is that
um you um you can say a lot of B you can
respond respond you can respond with
Bots as soon as you detect an error so
the third property said that each
message bit um um sorry that um the
number of message bits that should
actually be corrected uh decoded
correctly with probability at least half
plus Epsilon should be a constant
fraction of all the message bits yeah
but if you drop that kind of all bet are
off if you don't care um
what you're going to see I mean you can
have Bots all the time and that that
satisfies the yeah yeah
exactly yeah um can you say a little bit
about what locally updatable means
because it it sounds like it's kind of
so I I I it's it's a tension right so I
actually don't know the the crypto um
setup but yeah there is a tension
because they should be far from each
other yet you want to get to code work
so I I don't know exactly the S I just
kind of did search on local codes and um
ran into locally updatable code um but
yeah I don't actually
know more
questions all right if not we take else
offline and
take